India a country just filled with
wonderful culture your Bob's very big I
kiss your Bob's a country with men that
finally understands romance when I said
I can get you the moon I meant it
Vava great looking so hot
superb sexy beauty we have a lot of
stuff to learn from India still so today
we're going to jet dwell deeper into its
culture into its TV shows to try and
understand what makes India so great you
India you lose everybody Scott Dada
don't laugh let's begin the challenge
most dramatic scene ever okay let's
watch
[Music]
what's that
Oh
wait wait this can't be real this can't
be real
Jesus Christ this puts Brad won and Brad
to editing to shape what is this Jesus
Christ that was amazing Indian soap
opera scenes okay and do people complete
speedboat
I know it began now step out
John overlooked on it he said mother mom
need to me as I said to me
listen oh my god is beautiful
I need to watch some Indian dramas
clearly it reminds me of the sound from
there all diviners use in every single
clip
dramatic indian drama character
introduction okay let's watch
oh my god
why are my interest not that good this
is some next-level editing
it's like they just locked an editor in
the room and be like here's $2 and 500
grams of cocaine now edit this bit the
coolest way possible
dramatic Indian paper signing
[Music]
[Music]
this reminds me of a it's like a
real-life anime every myself Death Note
when he goes I take a potato ship solve
equations with my right hand and write
names maybe left I'll take a potato chip
hey friends were an Indian soap opera
take the rage lengthy rage lengthy rage
[Music]
oh my god oh my god this clip Brad is
gonna bread bread - it's gonna have to
do some proper censoring here bastard
bloody bastard you saw a faint rude
bloody thank you you don't blunder but
if I bloody know right bloody fool
bloody bloody bastard
running the gray dear oh what a move man
no socket meaning bloody bastard funny
boots I recommend watching this clip err
yeah in its full uncensored glory it's
absolutely beautiful and yeah it's just
a country filled with memes it's
absolutely beautiful here we have a ravi
posting on Facebook believe in yourself
and he he made his own book called
greatest people and he placed it next to
all these other famous people's books
someone commented cool he says yes I'm
proud of me how to transfer money from
GTA 5 to our original account helped me
I robbed a bank I have nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine dollars I want
to try and fur there's money to my Visa
debit card I care people say I look like
Ken a key Ken I mean he does have the
eyes just like the same size of the
pupils free likes you can't do because
because I poo is racist okay super funny
action scenes of Bollywood movies okay
bring it on
so this is a film apparently how is this
a movie
did they make this in gmod
wait there's Indian matrix oh my god is
the same movie why
[Music]
it's the same same please I mean
arguably this is better in my opinion
hello hello guys it's children and you
know what time it is
disco time and God
I mean there's this is basically me and
there's nothing to rip on here what's up
buddy good sir ISIL okay what are you
doing here sir
nothing much I'm just waiting for my
friend hey what's your friend's name my
friend name is Rhys is he staying at the
hotel here no he came to meet someone
over here so I'm just here to pick up my
wallet because I forgot my wallet in his
car I can see a driver's license use it
you can pull it up okay and this is not
yours I don't know what is this
I have no your story's still a little
scattered do you have anything else
illegal on your socks shoes anything
like that no okay I know you're high
okay
I smoke weed you're higher than you
think
no no it's because when I woke up I seen
the lights and stuff and I think you
guys I got nervous
I had a monster drink your tongues pasty
white that's all I got a thing I mean I
don't unless you want me to make up
stuff absolutely not probably being
honest I trust him I trust him okay he
was said he was being totally honest all
he did was have a monster energy drink
and a kebab this is the sort of racist
discrimination that poor de Mar de
marginalized groups face every single
day in America date a girl who wears
glasses it's like dating two girls when
she takes them off akaash says wash off
the makeup and then you can date three
women Savage
[Music]
why that's all I want to know why hope
you guys enjoyed this video did you
India or did you lose leave a like if
you lose and if Willie would like if you
won and I'll see you guys next episode
nothing finishes with my favorite song
of all time by Israeli to me goodbye to
the people who hate it on the vine
goodbye to the people I loved me
goodbye to the people who trusted me to
write goodbye to every party
[Music]
people love me imagine people who come
to me by like everybody